il y a Monsieur monsieur le Président
Monsieur rapporteur général chers
collègues nous entendons donc cet
après-midi monsieur Pierre-Louis brun
président du Conseil d'orientation des
retraites dans le cadre de la
préparation de la vie que devra rendre
notre commission sur le projet de loi de
financement rectificative de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023 notre collègue donc
Sylvie vermillier rapporteur pour notre
commission nous représentera son rapport
le 28 février prochain
avant sa présentation et avant
d'ailleurs que le texte ne nous arrive
au Sénat et nous a semblé utile vous
entendre monsieur le Président sur
l'évolution et les perspectives des
retraites en France l'organisme que vous
présidez est en effet une instance
indépendante et plus réaliste
d'expertise de concertation chargée
d'analyser de suivre les perspectives à
moyen et long terme du système de
retraite français
ces projections sont d'autant plus
importantes pour comprendre les
équilibres de notre système de retraite
par répartition et les modifications
qu'il convient d'apporter le cas échéant
pour assurer son financement de long
terme
notre commission des finances est par
ailleurs particulièrement attachés à
comprendre les enjeux à long terme tant
en recette qu'en dépense notre système
de retraite dans le cadre plus global de
l'évolution de nos finances publiques
votre audition monsieur le Président est
publique et les retransmise sur le site
internet du Sénat
je vous cède donc immédiatement la
parole pour un propos introductif avant
évidemment que la parole tourne
et que vous répondiez aux questions de
nos collègues c'est le président merci
monsieur le président
je vais donc dans un propos liminaire en
me concentrer sur la situation
financière de notre système de retraite
mais avant je voudrais vous vous
rappeler
ce qu'est le corps qui le constitue donc
le corps c'est une part des
parlementaires quatre députés et 4
sénateurs et je salue madame dermilliers
qui nous fait l'honneur de siéger parmi
nous
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux les
trois organisations représentatives des
employeurs et cette organisation
syndicale de salariés plus lunaf l'une
APL la Fédération nationale des
syndicats des crétins agricoles c'est
aussi toutes les administrations
concernées par la question des retraites
la direction générale du Trésor la
direction générale de la sécurité
sociale la direction du budget les
directions statistiques l'adresse la
DARES l'INSEE et c'est enfin des
personnalités qualifiées donc ce que je
vais vous présenter ces tissus du
rapport du corps c'est à dire c'est issu
d'un rapport qui a fait l'objet d'un
consensus je ne l'aurais pas publié sous
l'estampille au corps si tous les
membres qui constituent le corps ne
m'avait pas autorisé à le publier en
tant que rapports du corps donc je ne
vais pas vous livrer en tout cas je vais
essayer de ne pas vous livrer des
opinions personnelles mais de me rendre
compte d'un consensus entre toutes les
institutions enfin toutes les personnes
qui représentent des institutions que
j'ai que je vous ai détaillé alors le
premier élément
sur lequel je vous propose de nous
attarder un instant c'est le rapport des
dépenses de retraite à la richesse
nationale une retraite par répartition
ça veut dire qu'on prélève les
cotisations ou des impôts sur les actifs
pour financer les retraites et donc
c'est une manière synthétique de
d'apprécier le
l'effort qu'il faut faire pour les
retraités que de considérer le la part
des dépenses de retraite dans le clip en
gros ça dit c'est qu'il faudrait
prélever sur les actifs je ne vais pas
commenter le passé vous voyez que ça a
fortement augmenté dans les années 2000
le baby-boom la crise économique des
années 2010 vous avez le ce gros saut
lié au covid et puis en 2021 le dernier
chiffre connu c'est les dépenses de
retraite c'est très virgule 8% du PIB
vous voyez ensuite qu'il y a une seule
ligne jusqu'en 2030 parce que là nous
sommes calés sur les prévisions
économiques du gouvernement donc il n'y
a pas de il n'y a pas d'hypothèse à
partir de 2030 vous voyez que il y a
quatre courbes parce que nous sommes
amenés par consensus au sein du corps à
faire des hypothèses sur la croissance
de la productivité horaire du travail
qui détermine le niveau des salaires et
qui détermine aussi le niveau du niveau
du PIB et vous voyez que selon les
hypothèses que l'on prend on a des
résultats différents alors le spectre
d'hypothèse sur lequel nous travaillons
dans leur rapport c'est entre
0,7% de croissance annuelle de la
productivité du travail en gros ce qu'on
a connu entre
2009 et 2019
c'est la plus défavorable et la plus
favorable 1,6%, c'est en gros ce qu'on a
connu entre
1982 et 2022 d'accord sur 40 ans
vous voyez que les résultats sont très
différenciés globalement pour résumer
tout ça même s'il y a quelques vagues en
gros les dépenses de retraite sont
relativement stables vous voyez qu'il y
a quelques vagues et même à long terme
dans trois d'hypothèses sur quatre elle
diminue quelque peu puisque dans
l'hypothèse la plus favorable on finit à
11h 12% dans l'hypothèse orange je
précise que l'hypothèse orange 1% c'est
celle qui sert de référence pour la
réforme des retraites c'est c'est le cas
adopter le gouvernement parce que sinon
au corps nous pouvons gérer un spectre
d'hypothèse dans un rapport de constat
pour présenter une réforme il faut avoir
une seule référence et donc c'est
l'hypothèse orange qui a été retenue par
le gouvernement pas la plus pas la plus
défavorable mais celle qui suit
immédiatement il n'y a que dans
l'hypothèse grenat 07 % de croissance de
la productivité que les dépenses de
retraite augmentent quelque peu à
l'horizon 2050 puisqu'il passe de 13,8 à
14 14 4 je précise que 0 1 point de PIB
en 2021 le PIB c'était 2500 milliards et
que donc 01 point de PIB c'est 2,5
milliards je vais vous parler en
permanence en point de PIB donc pour
avoir une idée de ce que ça valait en
2021 retenez 01
= 2,5 1% =
25 parfait merci monsieur le président
donc
les dépenses de retraite ne dérapent en
priori ça crée souvent certaines
étonnements parce que la France est bien
évidemment aux cornes sommes conscients
que la science vieilli que la France
vieillit et elle vieillit tellement que
nous avons aujourd'hui 1,7 cotisant pour
un retraité et comme 2050 nous n'aurons
plus que 1,2 cotisants par retraité et
bien évidemment il n'y aurait que cette
évolution démographique
et bien les dépenses de retraite
augmenteraient fortement
en pourcentage du PIB néanmoins et vous
le voyez sur le slide le graphique qui
est à droite il y a un autre phénomène
très important c'est que les pensions
que l'on va verser à chacun des
retraités dans le temps vont diminuer
par rapport à la rémunération de chacun
des actifs et elles vont diminuer
d'autant plus que la croissance est
forte c'est pour ça que vous voyez que
ça diminue plus dans l'hypothèse verte
que dans l'hypothèse grenat alors
pourquoi ça diminue c'est parce que au
régime général les pensions sont
indexées sur les prix et donc quand les
salaires augmentent rapidement et bien
il y a un décrochage des pensions par
rapport au salaire et donc par rapport
au PIB c'est parce que Arco agir il y a
eu des mesures qui ont visé à faire
baisser durablement le rendement
technique d’arco Agirc et enfin la
fonction publique les périodes de gel du
point qui sont passés et qui sont
projetés dans nos dans nos hypothèses
boutissent aussi à peser sur le niveau
des pensions par rapport par rapport au
salaire donc
si j'ai pu vous dire que les dépenses de
retraite ne dérapaient pas c'est parce
que ces deux forces vont en sens
contraire et comme dans un problème de
physique élémentaire en gros et c'est un
hasard c'est pas quelqu'un qui qui l'a
voulu qu'il aurait organisé et bien elle
se contrebalance alors bien évidemment
si les pensions
des relatives des retraités baisse par
rapport aux rémunérations c'est c'est un
choix une question ça veut dire que
aujourd'hui le niveau de vie des
retraités et légèrement supérieur à
celui de l'ensemble de la population
même si on ne prend pas les loyers
imputés et les retraités sont souvent
souvent propriétaires que les autres
mais même sans loyer imputés c'est un
peu supérieur le niveau de vie et
du fait de la baisse relative des
pensions ce niveau de vie qui
aujourd'hui un peu supérieur l'ensemble
de la population
diminuerait pour se situer autour de 80%
alors qu'aujourd'hui il est à plus de
100% d'accord donc bien évidemment
si les dépenses de retraite ne dérapent
dans un contexte de vieillissement ça a
un revers qui est la baisse relative du
niveau des pensions et donc la baisse du
niveau de vie relatif des retraités par
rapport à l'ensemble de la population
voilà pour pour ce qui est des dépenses
de retraite par rapport au PIB
alors ensuite passons au solde
là vous avez en très plein le trait le
plus le plus le plus foncé
le niveau du solde de l'ensemble du
système de retraite
vous voyez que il a atteint un point bas
dans les années 2010 qu'en 2019 ont
frôlé l'équilibre qu'en 2020 bien
évidemment le solde s'est creusé avec le
covid et que en 2021 on était un peu en
dessous de l'équilibre 900 millions mais
comme on raisonne en 01 point de PIB on
dit que on est à l'équilibre puisque
c'est ça fait même pas 0 point de pipe
et vous voyez que ce solde on vous a
donné quatre groupes de régimes
il y a des régimes excédentaires c'est
les régimes complémentaires du privé et
il y a des régimes déficitaires c'est
les régimes de base du privé également
pour l'ensemble fonction publique et
indépendant on est très proche de
l'équilibre
ce solde je voudrais insister sur un
point vous avez peut-être entendu parce
que beaucoup de gens en parlent
l'idée que le corps cacherait 30
milliards de déficits d'accord alors
franchement je ne cache rien je n'ai
rien à cacher
c'est donner sont les données qui
servent de base aux lois de financement
de la sécurité sociale alors bien
évidemment comme on est sur l'ensemble
des régimes dans les lois de financement
de la sécurité sociale vous n'avez pas
les régimes complémentaires donc ce que
vous voyez dans les lois de financement
de la sécurité sociale c'est une branche
vieillesse qui est en déficit comme nous
on est sur l'ensemble des régimes de
retraite y compris complémentaires on
peut dire que en 2021 on est à
l'équilibre mais pour ce qui est des
régimes de base on prend les conventions
qui servent de base à la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale donc
le corps ne cache pas 30 milliards et
s'il y a 30 milliards de cachets c'est
30 milliards sont cachés par le
gouvernement vous transmet les documents
de base de la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale et ils sont cachés avec
la complicité de tous les groupes qui
constituent le Parlement puisque je n'ai
jamais vu remettre en cause dans les
débats sur les lois de financement de la
sécurité sociale j'ai bien vu qu'il y
avait des débats sur les modes finances
de sécurité sociale vous avez jamais
remis en code la nature même des des
soldes qui vous sont présentés en tout
cas la manière dont ils sont construits
donc nous les construisons comme ils
sont construits pour les lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale donc
si il y a quelque chose de caché ce
n'est pas le corps c'est caché par le
gouvernement avec complicité de tous les
groupes politiques et c'est une vraie
crise d'institutionnelle parce que ça
voudrait dire comment à tous les
Français je tenais à faire cette
précision parce que comme souvent on dit
le corps castral milliard je voudrais
que ce soit donc ça c'est le solde passé
et bien évidemment voilà le voilà le
solde en projection donc vous voyez que
on a repris l'observer le passé en 20 22
nous serons là en excédent on devrait
avoir plus de 0 un point de PIB
d'excédent mais vous voyez que tout de
suite après 2022 le solde se creuse et
il se creuse il y a différemment selon
les hypothèses économiques puisque vous
avez vu que la dynamique des dépenses
par rapport au PIB était différente
selon les hypothèses économiques et
alors là
un deuxième étonnement comment puis-je à
la fois vous dire que les dépenses ne
dérapent pas que nous sommes à
l'équilibre
la période initiale et que pour autant
nous allons être en déficit et bien
c'est parce que
la clé de cette énigme c'est l'évolution
des ressources alors c'est là où les
choses sont beaucoup moins intuitives
parce que ce que je vais vous dire ce
n'est pas immédiatement évident d'accord
alors les ressources c'est à dire le
taux de prélèvement pour les retraites
le taux de prélèvement des ressources
affectées aux retraites va diminuer si
on ne fait rien et il va diminuer sous
l'effet de 3 de trois phénomènes qui ne
sont pas intuitifs parce que a priori on
se dit les ressources pour les retraites
comme c'est des taux de cotisations
comme ces taux de cotisations sont sur
des bases de les rémunérations où il y a
quelques impôts aussi qui augmentent
comme le PIB si les taux de cotisations
ne bougent pas et bien les ressources
vont augmenter comme le PIB d'accord or
il y a quelques particularités le
premier c'est que le régime des
fonctionnaires et d'autres régimes
spéciaux qui sont équilibrés par des
subventions de l'État les ressources ne
dépendent pas d'une bave économique sur
lesquelles on prélaverait des
cotisations les ressources sont ajustées
sur les dépenses parce que une des
conventions qui sert de base à tous nos
textes c'est que le régime de retraite
des fonctionnaires de l'État et en
permanence équilibrée d'accord et donc
dans cette convention comme les
ressources dépendent des dépenses et
comme le régime des retraites est un
régime tellement vieux que les dépenses
de retraite des fonctionnaires vont
progressivement diminuer et sur 50 ans
en gros aujourd'hui c'est 2% du PIB de
50 ans les dépenses de retraite des
fonctionnaires ce sera 1% du PIB les
ressources affectées aux retraites
diminuent parce que les dépenses de
retraite des fonctionnaires diminuent
c'est le premier phénomène le deuxième
phénomène c'est que dans notre système
de retraite vous savez qu'on a une
multitude de régimes mais nous avons un
régime important qui s'appelle la CNRACL
c'est le régime de retraite des agents
des collectivités territoriales et des
hôpitaux et dans ce régime le taux de
cotisations est bien plus élevé que dans
le régime général et arcoagérique en
gros au régime général et Arco Agirc
c'est 28% comptant salarié et employeurs
et dans le régime CNRACL c'est 41 % or
il se trouve que la part des
rémunérations qui subissent ce taux plus
important c'est à dire les rémunérations
des agents des collectivités
territoriales et des agents hospitaliers
va diminuer dans l'ensemble des
rémunérations d'accord ça tient aussi
aux hypothèses qui ne font
communiquer par la Direction du Budget
sur l'évolution des rémunérations et des
effectifs
dans l'ensemble collectivités
territoriale et hôpitaux et donc vous
voyez que parce que la part de ces
rémunérations dans l'ensemble de
rémunérations diminue et bien il y a un
effet de structure qui fait que
globalement ça fera moins de ressources
pour le système c'est les deux
principaux phénomènes il y en a un
troisième qui est une ampleur
mais il y a des contributions
au système de retraite qui viennent de
la branche famille et de lunédique au
total ça fait environ 7% des ressources
du système de retraite pour prendre en
charge des avantages familiaux pour
prendre en charge notamment à coagir les
cotisations qui permettront au chômeurs
d'avoir des droits corrigés et comme
nous faisons l'hypothèse que demain il y
aura moins d'enfants c'est des
hypothèses de l'INSEE sur la fécondité
et qu'il y aura moins de chômeurs c'est
des hypothèses du gouvernement puisque
je voulais pas dit mais le gouvernement
prévoit qu'on soit 5% en 2027 et donc
nous on a prolongé
on a fait nos projections en prenant un
château de chômage à quatre et demi
stabilisés alors que d'habitude on
prenait 7 donc comme il y aura moins
d'enfants et moins de chômeurs et bien
les contributions familles et inédites
vont aussi diminuer donc vous voyez que
on peut dire à la fois que les dépenses
de retraite ne dérapent pas que
on est aujourd'hui à l'équilibre et que
pour autant le déficit va se creuser et
pour vous donner
une vision de la part de dans le solde
dans le déficit de ce qui rôde de ce qui
est attribuable au dépenses et de ce qui
attribuait attribuable recettes vous
avez un tableau je vous propose de
prendre
la ligne orange celle qui sert de base
au gouvernement pour pour la réforme
vous voyez l'évolution du solde donc en
2027 il est prévu moins 0,4.2 PIB moins
0,4 % du PIB en 2070 - 0,8 donc en
déficit qui se creuse mais vous voyez
que en 2027 par exemple et ça se dit de
cette manière il y aura un déficit de
moins 0,4
de -04% du PIB mais ça sera lié à -01 du
côté des dépenses et -03 du côté des
ressources d'accord ça c'est la
situation en 2027 si je me projette 20
ans après je prends la colonne 2046 vous
voyez qu'il y a un solde qui est à -07%
du PIB et que l'ensemble de ce solde
renvoie au phénomène ressources que je
vous ai décrit auparavant puisque en
2046 et bien il y aura le même niveau de
dépenses qu'il y avait en 2021 quand on
était à l'équilibre
donc voilà comment peut se analyser
l'évolution des dépenses des ressources
et du solde du système de retraite
maintenant ce que je voudrais souligner
auprès de vous c'est que même s'il est
dépenses de retraite ne dérapent pas
elles évoluent à un niveau qui n'est pas
compatible avec les objectifs de
finances publiques du gouvernement
je me réfère au dernier programme de
stabilité
les objectifs du gouvernement c'est de
réduire le déficit public à moins de 3%
à 29 en 2027 c'est de réduire ou de
stabiliser mais de réduire un peu les
prélèvements obligatoires et le
gouvernement en conclu sur un objectif
de dépenses qui a été affiché par Bruno
Le Maire était qui figure dans les
documents il ne faut pas que les
dépenses publiques dans leur globalité
augmentent de plus de 0,6% par an en
réel or les dépenses de retraite même si
elle ne dérapent pas vis-à-vis du PIB
augmente de 1,8% en réel et les dépenses
de retraite c'est 25% des dépenses
publiques or il est quasiment impossible
d'avoir 0,6 sur 100 dès lors que l'on a
un 8 sur 25 d'accord ou formuler
autrement si on a un 8 sur 25% c'est à
dire sur les retraites ça voudrait dire
qu'il faudra avoir une politique
extrêmement restrictive sur les autres
domaines de la dépense publique la
défense l'éducation la santé la justice
la police enfin je veux pas vous
énumérer tous les domaines de de la
dépense publique donc voilà ce qu'on
peut préciser sur
l'évolution des dépenses alors bien
évidemment au corps on a noté cette
difficulté mais bien évidemment certains
membres du corps ont tenu à préciser
qu'ils ne se sentait pas engagés par les
objectifs de finances publiques du
gouvernement donc on l'a noté parce
qu'il y a une contradiction mais tous
les tous les tous les membres du corps
ne se sentent pas engagés dernier point
pour en terminer la situation patrimoine
patrimoniale nette du système de
retraite donc la situation
nette du système de retraite c'est je
prends les dettes et je prends les
actifs et je regarde ce qui reste à la
fin alors il y a des réserves dans les
régimes en répartition c'est dans les
régimes complémentaires 180 milliards et
pour l'essentiel c'est pour la moitié
c'est des réserves à harcourir d'accord
il y a des réserves au fond de réserves
des retraites 26 milliards et il y a un
montant de dette à la cadette qui est
l'accumulation de des déficits qui ont
été repris par la cadette c'est 43
milliards ce qui fait qu'au total la
situation patrimoniale nette
des retraites c'est 163 milliards c'est
une des parties de la situation
patrimoniale nette des administrations
publiques et publiées chaque année par
l'INSEE et qui elle aussi positive à
hauteur de 375 milliards quand on fait
le bilan de ce que l'État possède et de
ce qu'il doit enfin l'état de l'ensemble
des administrations publiques ce que
possède l'ensemble des illustrations
publiques et ce qu'elle doivent et bien
il reste 375 milliards et les retraites
représentent à peu près la moitié de ce
patrimoine net publique pour autant je
ne voudrais pas que ce tableau vous
induisent un erreur c'est pas des
réserves que l'on pourrait
le problème c'est que ces réserves sont
dans les régimes qui sont excellentaires
et donc c'est pas avec les réserves
qu'on peut régler par exemple le déficit
à venir de du régime général ces
réserves elles sont pour l'essentiel je
voulais dire à quoi agir que la moitié
et elles sont dans un régime qui est
avant même la réforme
d'après une projection et d'ailleurs
celles qui sont reprises par le
gouvernement c'est les mêmes et bien est
excellentaire sur jusqu'en 2070 et sur
toute la période d'accord donc il y a
des réserves là où il y a des excédents
et où il y aura demain des excellents
d'accord donc et encore plus d'excédent
dès lors que il y aura eu la réforme des
retraites puisque le bilan pourra coagir
de la réforme des retraites en 2030
c'est environ
3,7 milliards d'euros je vous dis donc
je vous donne ce tableau mais attention
prenez-le en considérant que ces
retraites c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
peut gérer pour faire face à tel ou tel
déficit elles sont là enfin elles sont
localisées et la propriété des régimes
complémentaires et en particulier Darko
Agirc voilà monsieur le Président je
vais maintenir là sur les propos
liminaires
et répondre à vos questions
merci monsieur le Président je fais
peut-être donner la parole rapporteur
général ou un autre futur rapporteur
Sylvie vermeiller
cette présentation liminaire
[Musique]
le système de retraite c'est quand même
quelque chose de compliqué quand on y
passe pas sa vie
parce que c'est à la fois quelque chose
de spatial et de temporel donc on est
sur plusieurs dimensions qui font que il
faut toujours prendre en considération
des éléments très mouvants
moi je
comprends bien tout ce que vous venez de
nous exposer j'aimerais néanmoins pour
la bonne compréhension de tous que vous
puissiez peut-être revenir sur des
points qui me semblent fondamentaux
c'est peut-être revenir sur des
projections d'espérance de vie et de
démographie cette évolution de
l'espérance de vie
le nombre de données sens le nombre de
pensionnés le nombre d'actifs ça c'est
ce nœud central sur l'évolution des
retraites
le niveau de vie des retraités et
peut-être
parler aussi de l'équité entre
génération c'est que ce sont des
questions que beaucoup se posent
est-ce que finalement
être en retraite aujourd'hui où il y a
30 ans ou dans 30 ans est-ce que les
contributions des générations sont les
mêmes comment elles évoluent
et puis peut-être revenir un petit peu
sur ce qu'il nous revient de traiter ces
ce déficit et le projet de cette réforme
combien de peut-être caractériser un peu
les apports du projet de la réforme
quelles sont les cotisations
supplémentaires se capte les cotisations
supplémentaires à la fois en régime de
base et les régimes complémentaires
parce que on se focalise aujourd'hui sur
des équations des additions ou des
soustractions qui concernent le régime
de base on parle très peu des régimes
complémentaires est-ce que vous pouvez
aussi caractériser
les les bénéfices des régimes
complémentaires avec ce projet de
réforme et puis je m'en tiendrai là
parce que je vais aussi entendre toutes
les questions des collègues dans ma
mission de rapporteur merci
merci Sylvie peut-être monsieur le
Président vous pourriez répondre tout
d'abord à notre rapporteur et pendant ce
temps j'ouvre la liste qui est encore
peu fournie de ceux qui questionnent
oui bien évidemment derrière toutes ces
projections il y a des hypothèses
démographiques alors
au corps nous ne prétendons pas être
démographes et donc nous sommes calés
pour ce qui est des projections
centrales sur les projections de l'INSEE
et l'Insee révise ses projections tous
les quatre ou cinq ans les a révisés en
2021 donc les projections que nous
utilisons sont les projections de
l'INSEE je vous en rappelle les les
principaux éléments
l'Insee a pris acte d'une baisse de la
fécondité par rapport par exemple au
début des années 2000 et table sur une
stabilisation de l'indice conjoncturel
de fécondité à 1,80 jusqu'à la fin de la
période Lindsay
table sur une
un solde migratoire c'est à dire le
différence entre les entrées les sorties
du territoire des Français et des
étrangers de 70 000 par an et cela sur
toute la période alors bien évidemment
je pense que c'est un des domaines où
faire des projections et le plus le plus
aléatoire parce que ça dépend de
circonstances nationales et de
circonstances politiques intérieures que
personne ne maîtrise encore moins à
horizon de 50 ans la seule chose que je
peux dire c'est que
aujourd'hui les derniers chiffres que
nous avons sont un peu supérieurs à ces
70 000 mais c'est pas une information
pour dire il faut revoir les hypothèses
de l'Insee parce que c'est pas parce que
pendant deux ou trois ans on est un peu
en dessus de ce qui était prévu comme la
tendance qu'on va être au dessus pour
ceux qui est de l'évolution de la
longévité
l'INSEE en 2021 a revu un peu à la
baisse ce qu'elle prévoyait auparavant
c'est à dire qu'il va y avoir continuer
à avoir une augmentation de la longévité
une diminution de la mortalité mais un
rythme beaucoup plus faible que celui
qui
que nous connaissions auparavant alors
j'ai vu peut-être que vous y faisiez
allusion que mon casino homonyme le
démographe monsieur le bras considéré
que nous étions encore trop optimiste
sur la longévité j'ai pas j'ai pas
vocation à entrer dans un débat avec lui
puisque je vous l'ai dit moi je ne suis
pas démographe je prends
comme hypothèse centrale ce que nous
donne l'INSEE et je le prends aussi
parce que ça sert de base aux autres
projections du gouvernement à tous les
autres exercices de projection qui qui
se font mais bien évidemment
le débat est ouvert et
j'y participerai si je n'avais pas
simplement à vous rendre compte de ce
qui ne ce que nous de ce que nous
faisons sur le niveau de vie retraités
actif ou un centre de la population donc
aujourd'hui en gros depuis le milieu des
années 90 le niveau de vie des retraités
est supérieur à celui de l'ensemble de
la population alors vous pourriez me
dire mais vous nous avez dit que les
retraites c'était 50% du salaire moyen
mais il faut prendre pour calculer le
niveau de vie tous les revenus donc les
revenus du travail les pensions mais
aussi les revenus du capital
et surtout il faut ramener le revenu à
la composition de la famille en règle
générale les retraités non plus de
charges d'enfants alors que bien
évidemment dans l'ensemble de la
population les actifs ont souvent encore
en une charge une charge d'emploi donc
c'est à partir de là qu'on arrive à dire
depuis le milieu des années 90 le niveau
de vie des retraités en France est
supérieur à celui de l'ensemble des
actifs comme les pensions vont diminuer
relativement par rapport aux
rémunérations et bien ce niveau de vie
relatif va baisser alors avant de
commenter cette baisse je tiens à
préciser que les pensions vont diminuer
relativement
rémunération des actifs mais elles vont
néanmoins continuer à augmenter d'accord
une diminution relative par rapport aux
actifs ce n'est pas demain les retraités
seront plus pauvres qu'aujourd'hui c'est
demain les retraités feront plus pauvres
relativement aux actifs qui ne le sont
aujourd'hui mais demain le retraité sera
plus riche dans nos projections que le
retraité d'aujourd'hui donc en gros
la pension des retraités par rapport aux
rémunération des actifs ça fait une
diminution de ce niveau de vie relatif
qui va l'amener vers 80%, c'est en gros
la situation que nous connaissions en
France dans les années 80
donc voilà et c'est la situation que
connaissent d'autres pays comme la Suède
le Royaume-Uni ou l'Allemagne voilà
après je veux dire comparaison n'est pas
raison c'est parce que ils sont là que
c'est bien de les rejoindre voilà mais
c'est des éléments d'appréciation sur
sur cette diminution et cette diminution
elle est bien évidemment essentielle
parce que je le redis c'est celle qui
m'a permis de vous dire que les dépenses
de retraite ne dérapaient pas si on veut
maintenir le niveau de vie des retraités
par rapport aux actifs et bien là je il
faut prendre des mesures et dans ce cas
là les dépenses de retraite augmenteront
par rapport au PIB dernier dernier
élément
quand on projette le niveau de vie des
retraités par rapport aux actifs à très
long terme
la projection dont je vous présente les
résultats elle est mécanique
c'est-à-dire que elle est sa
modification des comportements des
futurs retraités or si le niveau de vie
des retraités futurs va diminuer par
rapport aux actifs il est possible que
les futurs retraités décident de réagir
par rapport à cette évolution alors
comment peuvent-ils réagir alors d'une
part déjà c'est ce qui le peuvent et
comme je vais vous dire comment ils
peuvent réagir vous verrez que tous ne
le peuvent pas mais ce qui ne peuvent
réagir en épargnant plus pendant leur
vie active pour avoir des revenus plus
de revenus du capital lorsqu'ils seront
retraités où ils peuvent réagir en
repoussant sans même qu'il y ait de
réforme des retraites contraignantes en
repoussant l'âge auquel il quitte leur
emploi parce que il y a quand on
repousse son âge de retraite et bien on
a une pension plus élevée voilà donc
voilà ce que je peux vous dire sur ces
questions de niveau de vie des retraités
et des actifs
sur
l'équité entre génération c'est c'est
très compliqué parce que pour juger de
ce qui se passe entre les générations il
faut voir ce que les générations
contribué et ce qu'elles vont toucher
alors sur la durée de retraite puisque
ils vont toucher ça dépend du montant
des retraites et de la durée sur la
durée de retraite elle a augmenté
jusqu'à la génération 50 la génération
50 celle qui est née en 1950 la
génération 50
juste après la génération 50 est entrée
en vigueur le report de 60 à 62 ans de
de la retraite c'était en 2010 et là la
durée de retraite a diminué et dans nos
projections je pense que on peut montrer
le slide voilà comment évolue la durée
de retraite avant réforme d'accord on
n'a pas mis les effets de la réforme
donc vous voyez la génération de 50 est
au maximum de la durée de retraite ça
diminue et en gros entre les générations
1955 et 1975 c'est quasi stable et puis
après ça recommence à augmenter parce
qu'il y a une augmentation de
l'espérance de vie et que dans nos
projections à partir de ce moment-là
l'âge de la retraite ne se décale plus
par rapport à ce à ce graphique qui est
avant réforme et bien vous l'avez vu la
réforme diminue réduirait
l'âge de départ
aboutirez à un report de l'âge de départ
à la retraite d'environ 7 mois et donc
vous pouvez décaler de 7 mois et c'est
pour la génération
1972 d'accord donc voilà pour ce qui est
de l'équité en termes de durée de
retraite d'accord en pourcentage du
temps de vie en gros c'est stable
quasiment stable autour de 28% on passe
28% de son temps de son temps à la
retraite
en termes de cotisation bien évidemment
les cotisations ont augmenté
continuellement depuis le début du
depuis le début du système donc
aujourd'hui
quelqu'un qui est actif il contribue
plus que ne contribuer ses parents
puisque on a augmenté régulièrement les
cotisations au régime général Arco agir
à la scène Racl et ainsi de suite et que
les taux de cotisations que nous avons
actuellement on ne les a jamais connues
auparavant donc les gens ont plus
contribué la le la durée de retraite a
augmenté puis abaissé
le niveau des pensions a augmenté mais
sans augmenter autant que les
que les rémunérations même si le niveau
de vie enfin augmentera moins que les
rémunérations donc le bilan
quand alors pour faire un bilan complet
il faut calculer des taux de rendement
interne entre les contributions et les
cotisations retenez monsieur des calculs
compliqués que c'est stable et que ça va
un peu augmenter en fin de période voilà
je dis aussi que on peut pas
porter une appréciation sur l'équité
entre générations
sur les retraites sans considérer ce qui
se passe dans
hors retraite or quelqu'un qui le niveau
de vie moyen aujourd'hui c'est deux fois
le niveau de moyen de 1960 d'accord donc
quelqu'un qui vit aujourd'hui de toute
façon il vit beaucoup mieux enfin en
termes de niveau de vie porte pas de
jugement moral ou culturelle sur est-ce
que c'était mieux avant mais en terme de
niveau de vie c'est deux fois et demi
donc
on ne peut pas considérer l'équité entre
génération au niveau des retraites sans
considérer que et bien il vaut mieux
être
moyen en 2022 qu'être moyen en 1960 et
l'augmentation de l'espérance de vie a
été de 15 ans sur toute cette période
également donc voilà il faut replacer la
question de l'équité de génération dans
l'équité générale enfin dans les
évolutions générales
sur le déficit
je l'ai un peu évoqué donc
le déficit global donc on a 42 régime
mais en gros on a quatre régimes majeurs
le régime de base des salariés du privé
Arrco Agirc le régime de retraite des
fonctionnaires de l'État et la scène
régime de retraite des fonctionnaires de
l'État par construction
par une convention qui est commune à
tous qui n'est pas que la convention du
corps il est en permanence équilibré
donc on peut difficilement débattre donc
où sont les déficits où vont-ils être
ils sont au régime général
régime général et FSV et à la cnracell
d'ailleurs vous l'avez vu il est prévu
dans le projet de réforme une
augmentation des taux de cotisations
spécifiques à la cnrcl dans le dans le
projet de réforme où sont les excédents
ils sont à arcoagiques ils étaient arché
agir dans le passé et si vous regardez
les
documents du gouvernement mais qui sont
la reprise du corps dans l'hypothèse 1%
de croissance de la productivité Arco
agirk reste excédentaire sur toute la
période il respectait dentaire jusqu'en
2070 donc il n'a pas besoin d'utiliser
d'utiliser ces réserves
la réforme elle-même c'est en rendement
pour arcoager quand on enlève les
mesures d'accompagnement je pense de
trois,5 milliards donc sur les 12
milliards il y a 3,5 milliards d'Arco
Agirc donc effectivement c'est une
question est-ce que ces 3,5 milliards
viendront alimenter les réserves et donc
feront vraiment un rendement de la
réforme ou est-ce que les dernières
sociaux
dès lors qu'ils ont des réserves qui
sont au-delà de la norme de pilotage qui
se sont donnés ils sont donnés comme
normes de pilotage 6 mois de prestation
retraite sous forme de réserve ils sont
plutôt à 8,9 mois est-ce que ils vont
ils vont pas se dire on était on était
annexé avec la réforme on a encore plus
d'excellents après que faisons-nous de
cet excédent c'est une c'est une c'est
une évolution plausible en tout cas ce
qui serait
dire logique j'en sais rien mais je veux
pas préjugé des décisions qui prendront
mais c'est une des questions
effectivement on a un régime il y a un
solde global c'est celui dont je vous ai
parlé mais il faut regarder après
comment se décompose ce sol je crois
qu'il y a beaucoup trop parlé je suis à
votre écoute j'ai peur que si les
questions sont complexes la réponse ce
sont un peu longue
pareil
sur le rapporteur général
merci monsieur le Président moi je vais
vous poser très rapidement trois
questions une première sur la question
du finalement du niveau de pension et du
niveau des cotisations qui sont
considérés aujourd'hui comme des
alternatives à un allongement sur la
durée d'activité est-ce que vous
pourriez nous rappeler quel est l'impact
sur l'équilibre financier du système que
pourrait que ça pourrait avoir notamment
sur le niveau des pensions et sur celui
des cotisations s'il y a pas de
prolongement de prolongation pardon de
la durée d'activité deuxièmement
la réforme est aujourd'hui
indispensable pour garantir un niveau de
pension de retraite pour tous les
pensionnés actuels et futurs mais quel
est d'après vous concrètement le risque
de baisse des pensions versées en
l'absence de modification des conditions
actuelles de financement du régime et
puis pour revenir sur votre rapport il
indique que le système pour être
équilibré dans le scénario central que
vous avez évoqué avec un âge
conjoncturel de départ un peu plus de 64
ans
64 ans
2 en 2032 donc c'est un peu supérieur à
ce qui est retenu actuellement est-ce
que on peut en conclure qu'il faudra
revenir
un moment donné d'ici quelques années
sur cet âge de 64 ans
ou pas et je dis bien à horizon de
quelques années
merci Monsieur à partager monsieur le
Président on va prendre maintenant
l'ensemble des questions et vous allez
être autorisé un exercice obligatoire me
semble-t-il c'est pour pas tout mélanger
à reprendre par domaine par typologie de
questions et regrouper sans forcément
citer le nom de nos collègues voilà mais
faire par thématique sinon vous allez
pas vous en sortir vous avez passé d'un
thème à un autre et puis revenir sur le
premier thème voilà je vous laisse
manœuvrer si je puis dire
très bien Pascal ça vaut le délit puis
Thierry Cozic
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur général pour cette initiative
elle nous donne des éléments et merci à
vous monsieur le Président pour les
explications nous donner j'ai trois
questions la première dans les
phénomènes sur la question du sol vous
les avez abordés dans votre introduction
vous l'avez pu les lire auparavant vous
avez évoqué les baisses des dépenses de
retraite de l'État employeur pour ces
fonctionnaires
vous avez évoqué le deuxième phénomène
qu'il est fait scénarcl qui est assez
intéressant puisque en résumé vous me
direz s'il le formule de bonne manière
mais ceux qui cotisent le plus
cotiseront moins en proportion de la
somme des cotisations
d'où ma première question c'est vous
demander quel est l'effet de la
politique d'emploi public et des
rémunérations du gouvernement sur le
déficit du système de retraite ça c'est
ma première question la seconde question
la
c'est une question qui va intéresser la
réponse va intéresser mes collègues
républicains puisque mes collègues
républicains lors de la loi de Finances
avait fait une proposition qui a été
votée par une majorité
de supprimer 150 000 emplois de
fonctionnaires vous en rappelez mes
chers collègues voilà je voudrais vous
demander monsieur le Président de
combien ça en putterait les recettes de
la sécurité sociale si cette proposition
était retenue dans une loi de
programmation c'est intéressant de
savoir
où c'est et la dernière chose pourrait
être cohérent avec ce que je viens de
dire
la troisième chose pour rester cohérent
j'ai pu et c'est intéressant même si ça
demande s'il vient mais elle l'a dit
quand même de d'y travailler mais si
j'ai bien compris
on se base vous basez sur deux
conventions donc une qui est l'équilibre
permanent des retraites et l'autre qui
les efforts de l'État constant qui sont
des acronymes que j'ai dû découvrir je
vous avoue qu'avant le CC je savais pas
ce que c'était et vous avez évoqué j'ai
pu voir ça dans d'autres auditions à la
presse une convention historique du
corps qu'est-ce que vous entendez par
une convention historique et le
gouvernement lui fait un choix
c'est de retenir la convention de
l'équilibre permanent des retraites et
il a décidé de pas faire le choix de
l'effort de l'État constant alors est-ce
que je dois comprendre que le déficit du
système de retraite qui est annoncé et
augmenté je mets des guillemets
artificiellement par un désengagement de
l'État autour de 1,2 points de PIB soit
et c'est là qu'on a la session de
rattrapage puisque les 1,2% de PIB qui
serait fabriqué artificiellement et ben
nous voilà dans les 30 milliards donc
voilà mes questions merci merci Pascal
avec un art de synthèse un peu plus
développé Thierry Cozic merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Président ce
que je comprends votre exposé
aujourd'hui c'est que le financement des
déficits il est à la fois porté par les
actifs et les routes et les retraités
donc c'est le modèle qui a été retenu
par le gouvernement
pourtant j'ai le sentiment qu'il y a
deux autres modalités de financement de
notre système de retraite qui est
possible la première elle est assez
basique ce serait de dépenser moins et
mieux et la seconde serait d'augmenter
les recettes des comptes sociaux qui
sont volontairement diminués aujourd'hui
pour rappel en octobre 2022 l'IRES a
montré que les aides publiques aux
entreprises sont passées 3% du PIB en
2000 à 6,4% du PIB en 2019 soit un total
de 157 milliards d'euros constitués
notamment d'exonération de charges
sociales qui réduisent d'autant les
recettes des comptes sociaux ces mesures
ne sont pas neutres lors de la première
mise en oeuvre de cette politique en
2007 sous le quinquennat Sarkozy cyprès
3 milliards d'euros par an qui est qui a
été perdu
finalement j'ai le sentiment que le
gouvernement aujourd'hui joue un peu aux
pompiers Pyroman il affirme vouloir
sauver le retrait le système de retraite
par frais partition qu'il a lui-même
contribué à déséquilibrer de surcroît le
choix diminuer le montant total des
pensions de retraite mécaniquement
réalisé par la réduction de leur durée
aboutit à réduire la protection offerte
par le système de répartition tout
spécifiquement pour les catégories
populaires qui en bénéficient déjà moins
cette façon de entre guillemets sauver
le système par répartition et de mon
point de vue une forme de démantèlement
enfin je pense qu'il y a une autre
police une autre politique qui serait de
revoir la baisse certaines dépenses
publiques dans votre rapport en page 15
de vous indiquer que de 2022 à 2032 la
situation financière du système de
retraite se détériorerait avec un
déficit allant de 0,5 points à 0,8
points de PIB soit en très soit entre 13
et 19 milliards d'euros rapporté un PIB
de 1354 milliards en 2022 une baisse des
dépenses publiques aux entreprises des
proportions équivalentes sont d'autant
plus réalisables que cette politique
d'aide peu ciblée
et que son efficacité en termes
d'emplois et croissance et controversé
et je fais notamment référence un
rapport de l'irès en 2022 à mon sens il
n'existe également pas de raison pour
que les déficits accumulés notamment
raison de la politique du quoi qu'il en
coûte soit financé par les seuls
salariés retraités dans le pouvoir
d'achat baisse en raison d'une
indexation partielle sur le niveau de
l'inflation donc ma question c'est
pensez-vous que la logique comptable que
je viens d'exposer soit de nature à
tracer une perspective crédible pour le
financement des déficits à venir merci
merci
je vais passer la parole à Roger
carottier mais je vous rappelle qu'ici
le président du corps indique ce qu'est
la comment dire ce que l'étude des
retraites à partir de ce qui est
aujourd'hui
comment dire
fait par consensus si je puis dire et ce
qui est l'état de l'art si je puis dire
et après évidemment on peut pas demander
me semble-t-il au président du corps de
faire une analyse politique de ce qu'il
devrait faire ce qui pourrait être fait
je crois qu'il ne serait pas dans son
rôle et je ne crois pas qu'il souhaite
répondre je l'indique à des questions
qui seraient des alternatives voilà je
ceci étant dit je n'empêche pas Roger
caoutchi d'évoquer le sujet quand même
impossible monsieur le Président d'abord
premier point moi je regarde les
statistiques là par exemple sur
l'évolution du rapport entre les
retraités les actifs sur le niveau de
vie et tout mais pardon de dire ça me
paraît un peu
illusoire
un retraité par définition a été actif
toute sa vie qu'il est épargné qu'il a
acheté son logement qui n'est plus de
charge de loyer qui n'est plus de charge
d'enfants et en réalité il a pas
franchement revenu très nettement
supérieur à ce que ceux et en parallèle
le revenu de l'actif mais pendant toute
sa vie la composé une épargne il a plus
de charge d'enfant donc on peut dire il
a un niveau de vie nettement supérieur
mais dans le débat public il faut pas
laisser croire que ça veut dire que les
retraités sont ultra favorisés ils sont
en réalité dans une situation qui est
évidemment très différente à 70 ans qu'à
25 ans et en termes de patrimoine et en
termes d'enfants à charge ce qui n'est
pas du tout la même chose deuxième point
monsieur le Président
je vois bien toutes ces évolutions mais
j'ai regardé les rapports pas seulement
du corps mais de bien de nos débats
parlementaires des 20 dernières années
en réalité
on est extrêmement prétentieux on pense
tous faire la réforme qui va
naturellement rééquilibrer les comptes
et on est tous prétentieux de dire voilà
les équilibres mais les équilibres ils
changent terriblement en fonction du
solde migratoire du sol démographique de
la politique familiale conduite de la
relation au travail pas seulement sur la
durée mais sur la relation au travail de
la capacité d'épargne etc donc est-ce
qu'il faudrait pas un jour se dire
écoutez on met en place une réforme
quelle qu'elle soit pour assurer
l'équilibre des comptes mais on accepte
l'idée que du fait de l'évolution de la
société et de la relation par rapport au
travail et bien on remet un petit peu
les compteurs à l'équilibre par exemple
tous les 10 ans en fonction de
l'évolution des politiques parce qu'ici
le côté quasiment totémique c'est 64 ans
c'était 62 ans 2010 la guerre de sens à
mon sens par rapport aux évolutions ils
vont avoir lieu est-ce qu'on est capable
d'être un peu souple
merci Roger Sébastien Meurant puis
Daniel broyer merci monsieur le
Président mais oui en fait la réforme
des retraites c'est la réforme du
travail et la réforme de la production
de richesse c'est ça en fait qui
détermine le montant de ce qu'on peut
avoir à la retraite moi deux questions
sur le régime de la scénar ACN puisque
effectivement il est prévu d'une hausse
des taux mais la première ministre je
crois a annoncé une compensation donc
sur l'équilibre je m'interroge après les
questions précises sur le nombre de
retraités nés à l'étranger s'il vous
plaît le nombre de pensionnés né à
l'étranger bénéficiant de la SPA et
l'évolution également du montant j'ai lu
que une pension sur cinq comportait des
erreurs
et il va savoir qu'est-ce qu'il en est
selon vous et notamment une évolution du
menton du menton des défauts et
notamment une question plus précise ce
rapport de la Cour des comptes de 2017
donc j'avais posé la question au
gouvernement moi sur les centenaires qui
s'était évalué par an à 200 millions
d'euros de fraude est-ce que des choses
ont évolué de ce côté-là merci merci
Sébastien Daniel Bruyer puis Michel
canevé merci merci monsieur le Président
de la présentation bon par bonheur et
pas par hasard mais mes collègues
socialistes et communistes sont posés
deux questions que je souhaitais poser
donc je voudrais préciser pour ma part
une question du rapporteur général dans
l'hypothèse où on choisirait une hausse
des cotisations plutôt qu'un allongement
de la durée du travail quelle serait
cette hausse et je parle pas de la
répartition employeur salariée quelles
seraient cette hausse pour un smicard et
qu'elle serait cette hausse pour un
salaire à 3000 euros en fait moi je
souhaite comprendre la différenciation
sociale j'ai la même question de
différenciation vous nous avez présenté
un graphique sur la durée de vie à la
retraite
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter
selon pour les catégories les plus
modestes et pour les catégories les plus
aisées cette durée de vie à la retraite
j'imagine que vous avez les chiffres et
enfin je ne sais pas si ça vous est
possible mais j'aimerais comprendre
combien les mesures de désocialisation
des heures sup et des primes que qui ont
été évoquées notamment par Thierry
koszick retire au caisse de retraite je
parle des mesures effectives et ma
dernière question très simple c'est
est-ce que les réformes précédentes ont
eu un impact sur le taux d'emploi des
seniors
et si oui lequel
merci Daniel Michel canvett puis
Christine lavardde merci monsieur le
Président du corps pour votre exposé à
ces pédagogiques mais ça ne m'étonne pas
puisque en breton brasse veut dire grand
donc cela mène m'étonne pas que vous
ayez plus de bien nous présenter les
choses alors on est quand même en
situation assez paradoxale puisque on
parle beaucoup de déficit des budgets de
la retraite or finalement on arrive à
une situation qui est excédentaire on a
aussi je dirais de réforme qui amène à
croître la la durée de cotisation qui
est planifié jusqu'à un certain temps on
a un peu de mal finalement à savoir si
véritablement en fait rapidement en
situation déficitaire ou pas on a plutôt
le tendance à penser que bah si
finalement on est en situation d'emplois
plutôt pas mal elle devrait encore
s'améliorer selon le gouvernement et
donc
et donc
on peut penser que les cotisations vont
rentrer que avec l'allongement enfin la
mise en place la réforme Touraine
finalement il faut
on va avoir plus de temps de travail et
donc
moi sans doute de pension à verser alors
est-ce qu'il faut vraiment jusqu'à quand
le régime est équilibré et est-ce qu'il
faut vraiment tout de suite engager la
réforme
merci Michel Christine lavard depuis
Vincent seboin merci monsieur le
Président alors j'avais bien conscience
que ma question était un peu hors sujet
par rapport aux travaux du corps mais ça
me permettra de dire qu'il y a d'autres
pistes alternatives que celles qui ont
été présentées de l'autre côté de la
salle et notamment ce qui serait
intéressant de voir c'est si jamais on
accepte de à côté du régime par
répartition peut-être de mettre en place
un régime par capitalisation qui
permettrait d'assurer dans la durée en
fait à un niveau de pension satisfaisant
pour tous c'est ça est-ce que c'est des
hypothèses que vous regardez même si
elle figure pas dans le rapport vous
vous interdisez vraiment de penser un
paradigme autre que celui aujourd'hui de
100% répartition
je crois que j'ai la réponse Christine
Vincent Segoin puis Christian BIAC oui
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président une question si on ne réforme
pas l'âge de débat en retraite on a deux
autres moyens c'est augmenter les
cotisations baisser des pensions les
pensions ce qui a déjà été fait puisque
on a créé la CSG et hausser les
cotisations c'est la méthode qu'on a
toujours suivi ma question c'est
alors quel est le montant de
l'augmentation des cotisations pour
venir l'équilibre qu'il faut prévoir et
quel est l'effet sur la compétitivité et
sur la balance commerciale
question large merci Vincent Christian
biyac pyjean-marie maison
merci monsieur le Président
pour votre exposé alors vous nous avez
présenté un certain nombre d'hypothèses
de prévision vous me pardonnerez
ma jeunesse en matière de commission des
finances mais
à l'automne 2020 nous avons reçu
plusieurs prévisionnistes plus
germinants les hommes que les autres de
l'OCDE à la Banque de France en passant
par directeur du Trésor qui nous
expliquait que le covid à sa fin et que
l'avenir était radure patatras reprise
de covid à l'automne 2021 là le covid
est terminé et l'avenir était radieuse
avec une inflation maîtrisée etc
patatras la guerre nous graine
pardonnez-moi moi j'ai toujours
désormais un peu decepticisme quand on
me présente des prévisions parce que
tout simplement présenté jusqu'à
aujourd'hui elles se sont avérées
au gouvernement pour les 5 à l'avenir il
était prévu une contribution des
organismes secrètes sociales de 25
milliards
pour retrouver le déficit à 3% est-ce
que l'allongement de la durée du
cotisations
combien ça pèse par rapport à ces 25
milliards que le gouvernement prévoyait
dans son plan de programmation pour le
redressement des finances publiques
merci Christian Jean-Louis Jean-Marie
pardon maison j'ai pas d'autres demandes
si merci
monsieur le Président certains
commentateurs avaient toujours avisés
les commentateurs disent que la France a
moins besoin d'une réforme des retraites
que de retrouver des marges de manœuvre
vous l'avez d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
évoquez-vous même parce que si par
exemple on n'avait pas en France
supprimé la taxe d'habitation sur les
résidences principales pour on verra
environ 20 milliards d'euros par an la
CVAE pour presque 10 milliards d'euros
la taxe sur l'audiovisuel pour près de 4
milliards d'euros c'est à dire on aurait
peut-être pas besoin d'une réforme aussi
urgente des retraites mais ce sont des
commentateurs et je sais que ça rentre
pas dans votre dans votre champ de
d'analyse moi je voulais savoir si
l'article qui focalise beaucoup des
critiques à savoir l'article 7 qui
traite de l'âge pivot devait ne pas être
voté dans cette réforme quel serait le
manque à gagner par rapport à vos
hypothèses
merci Jean-Marie maison et merci de
rejoindre les clubs rhénaliens sur la
vision sur la CVAE etc
ce sont des évolutions positives il faut
savoir les marquer
Bernard delcroz oui merci monsieur le
Président je serai de très bref parce
que la question a été posée par un
collègue mais pour être sûr qu'elle
passe pas la trappe je la repose si on
voulait obtenir exactement le même
objectif que celui que prévoit la
réforme à travers des crédits financiers
en substituant au report de l'âge légal
deux années supplémentaires dans le
substituant l'augmentation des
cotisations de quel taux faudrait-il
augmenter les cotisations
je vous laisse finir d'écrire
avant de vous donner la parole on a
terminé je crois qu'il y a pas d'autres
questions mais enfin il y en avait déjà
suffisamment me semble-t-il c'est le
président ouais donc comme vous l'avez
dit monsieur le Président moi je suis là
pour rendre compte des travaux du corps
et donc il y a eu des appréciations sur
pas de réforme la réforme voilà je sais
pas mon c'est pas mon rôle que de vous
donner mon opinion et en plus elle
aurait assez peu d'importance je vais
donc essayer de répondre aux diverses
aux diverses questions alors
donc sur les conventions donc vous avez
évoqué la le fait que dans le rapport il
y a deux conventions la convention EPR
et la convention EC vous avez vu que
dans mon exposé je n'ai évoqué que la
convention EPR c'est à dire la
convention qui sert de base aux lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale
pourquoi n'a j'évoqué que cette
convention parce que la convention EC
c'était une manière que nous estimons
pédagogique de montrer ce qui se passait
s'il n'y avait pas le premier phénomène
sur que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure si tu
peux remettre le slide
je vous ai dit que si les ressources
baissées c'est parce qu'il y avait trois
phénomènes la convention EC ça consiste
à gommer le premier phénomène d'accord
comme nous avons senti d'une part parmi
certaines membres du corps les
réticences par rapport à cette
convention et puis d'autre part le fait
qu'elle était mal comprise parce que
bien évidemment les membres du corps ne
se considèrent pas comme ayant vocation
après hanté ce que l'État va faire
puisque sur les économies qu'il va faire
puisqu'il aura moins à payer de retraite
pour ses fonctionnaires
on devrait écarter la convention et
aussi en tout cas c'est ce que je
présente proposerai au membres du corps
mais en termes pédagogique vous avez
toute l'information c'est le tableau qui
suivait qui vous permet de voir ce qui
dans l'évolution du solde est liée au
dépenses et aux ressources et donc dans
ce que vous voyez comme évolution du
truc du taux de prélèvement et bien il y
a l'inverse de ce que donnait la
convention EC je sais pas si je suis
clair mais en parlant d'une seule
convention qui est celle qui sert de
base de LSS je pense qu'on simplifie le
débat mais néanmoins vous donne toutes
les informations en vous disant ce qui
dans le solde et
et lié au départ et au taux de
prélèvement
il y a certaines questions qui m'ont dit
voilà ça c'est le solde avant réforme
donc voilà si on considère puisque
certains ont dit mais est-ce que il faut
est-ce qu'on pourrait prendre du temps
dehors alors là je vous ai donné le sol
en 2027 je vous ai dit qu'en 2022 on le
ferait un excédent mais dès 2023 et 2024
avec les prévisions actuelles on devrait
être en déficit donc je vous ai donné
voilà vous le voyez donc après moi je
n'ai pas apporté de de jugement sur il y
a urgence il y a pas urgence je n'ai
qu'à vous dire que en Italie en 2021 on
sera un excédent 2022 et ensuite et bien
le solde va se dégrader et après c'est à
la représentation nationale et le
gouvernement de prendre les décisions de
prendre des décisions qui s'imposent
alors on m'a aussi beaucoup demandé
mais si on repousse pas l'âge et si on
agit par les cotisations ou le niveau
des pensions
à quoi ça correspondrait alors j'ai pas
les calculs dans les termes où vous avez
posé la question parce que je n'ai pas
une calculette et je ne suis pas un
ordinateur je vous renvoie sur le site
du corps
on a fait les calculs sur on veut
équilibrer en moyenne le système sur les
25 prochaines années d'accord
il y a trois possibilités on augmente
l'âge on augmente les pensions
on en pardon on augmente les cotisations
on diminue les pensions en tout cas on
les diminue pas en valeur nominale les
sous index ça prend des tableaux que
vous trouverez sur le site du corps
comme vous envoyer de cette forme là
alors c'est pas évident mais en gros je
prends de combien faut-il augmenter ou
diminuer le taux de prélèvement pour
atteindre l'équilibre en moyenne sur les
25 prochaines années d'accord on n'est
pas sur 10 ans comme le gouvernement on
avait pris 25 ans parce que c'est ce qui
est prévu par décret donc je me situe
dans
l'hypothèse 1% le taux de prélèvement
sur l'ensemble des rémunérations en 2021
c'est 31,2 d'accord
si on ne fait rien comme je vous l'ai
dit le taux de ressources baisse ce taux
il va être à moyenne sur les 25 ans de
30,1%. d'accord
quelle est l'évolution nécessaire par
rapport au taux spontané c'est 1% c'est
à dire qu'au lieu de prélever 30% des
rémunérations donc les retraites c'est
30% des rémunérations il faudrait passer
prélever 31% enfin 30,1 il faudrait
prendre prélever
31,1%. quelle est l'évolution nécessaire
par rapport au taux initial c'est zéro à
l'horizon 25 ans parce que il y a déjà
une baisse voilà en gros on est 31-2-31
d'accord voilà donc ces tableaux là je
les tiens à votre disposition alors je
les on les a calculés sur 25 ans parce
que c'est ce que nous prévoit le décret
maintenant la nouvelle norme c'est à 10
ans on pourrait refaire les mêmes choses
sur il y a 10 ans mais franchement la
retraite c'est un paquebot
donc il vaut mieux prendre quand même
certaines
voilà peut-être qu'il faut pas aller
jusqu'à 50 ans et d'ailleurs c'est pour
ça enfin pardon il faut se donner la
visibilité jusqu'à 50 ans mais après on
peut se donner des règles de pilotage à
moins et c'est pour ça que dans le
décret on nous dit de faire un focus sur
25 ans ce que nous ce que nous avons
fait
et voilà comment ça pourrait fonctionner
alors je crois que j'ai la même chose
avec de combien faut-il augmenter ou
diminuer la pension relative pour
atteindre l'équilibre en moyenne sur les
25 prochaines années donc on part d'un
niveau où les tensions relatives je vous
l'ai dit en 2021 c'est 50% des
rémunérations d'accord
spontanément ça va baisser à 47 heures
en moyenne sur les 25 millions d'années
et il faudrait que ça baisse par rapport
à la pension initiale de
-6,5 de plus d'accord et par rapport à
la pension à l'évolution spontanée
c'est-à-dire ça va baisser de toute
façon même si on ne fait rien il
faudrait que ça baisse de 3,4% de plus
c'est-à-dire que au lieu d'avoir 47 ans
sur les 25 meilleures années il faudrait
qu'on ait 47 hommes ou une 3,4 je
voulais faire le calcul mental donc
voilà ces tableaux on les tient à votre
disposition
on pourrait le faire sur 10 ans mais
nous ne demandez pas parce que je suis
pas sûr qu'on aurait techniquement les
moyens de refaire tous les calculs sur
10 ans mais vous les avez sur 25 ans et
ça vous donne ça vous donne les ordres
de grandeur des des hypothèses
alternatives
à la question
on agit par l'âge
sur le côté
il y a eu plein de remarques du genre
oui mais quand on prévoit l'avenir on
sait jamais et puis on est toujours déçu
d'accord je suis entièrement d'accord
avec vous je ne sais pas quelle est
l'avenir je ne sais pas plus que vous et
le métier le plus difficile c'est
d'essayer enfin ce qui est facile c'est
de c'est de prédire sur le passé mais
sur l'avenir c'est un peu plus compliqué
donc je n'ai pas de boule de cristal je
ne suis pas Madame Irma je ne sais pas
plus que vous la question c'est que il
faut quand même prendre les décisions
d'accord et je ne vous et je ne prétends
pas je veux dire je vous avoue que
parfois j'ai le vertige quand je fais
ces courbes d'accord parce qu'en 2070 je
ne serai plus là enfin l'hypothèse que
je sois là elle est vraiment extrêmement
minime d'accord et je menais quand je
quand j'entends parler de la guerre
d'Ukraine des menaces nucléaires du
réchauffement climatique de l'attention
avec la Chine ainsi de suite je me dis
mais est-ce que je devrais pas ranger
tout ça et aller cultiver mon jardin si
je continue c'est parce que j'ai
conscience aussi que même si peut
arriver plein de choses il faut dans
cette démocratie qu'on continue à
prendre des décisions sur les retraites
et ainsi de suite et que pour prendre
cette décision il faut être un peu
éclairé donc quand je vous fais ces
projections c'est pas pour vous dire
c'est des prévisions sur un an on peut
essayer de faire des prévisions quand on
se quand on est à 50 ans on fait des
projections et on essaie de faire des
projections raisonnables et raisonnées
c'est ce qu'on fait avec les membres du
corps et ainsi de suite pour orienter
les débats et orienter les décisions
parce que sinon vous nous diriez mais
voilà vous seriez aussi extrêmement
démunis donc voilà voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire par rapport à
l'exercice semaine que fait le corps
nous essayons de ne pas être prétentieux
nous savons que nous ne connaissons pas
l'avenir mais nous faisons ce travail
parce que nous pensions qu'il peut être
utile s'il ne l'est pas dites-le-moi
j'irai faire autre chose je peux faire
des missions Vegas qui seront peut-être
utiles voilà
convention niveau de pension
oui sur
sur les exonérations donc
en gros pour ce qui est de la retraite
les exonérations sont compensées
d'accord donc voilà à part toute petite
celle que vous évoquez sur les sur les
sur les heures supplémentaires mais par
rapport aux enjeux de 345 milliards de
dépenses et en 2018
c'est l'épaisseur du trait donc je crois
que nous le mentions leur rapport mais
ça doit être une phrase parce que c'est
c'est pas à la hauteur de des questions
que nous nous posons
voilà donc je vais pas répondre aussi
sur le fait qu'on pourrait réduire notre
dépense c'est pas mon c'est pas
c'est pas à moi de le dire sur les
étrangers il y a donc
notre système de retraite on ouvre des
droits avec des cotisations et depuis
l'origine on s'ouvre le droit qu'on soit
français ou étranger dès lors qu'on
travaille en France au nouveau ses
droits
que l'on soit français ou étranger si on
a déménagé et qu'on vit à l'étranger et
bien on touche les droits à la retraite
c'est la base d'un système contributif
ou les droits sont générés par le fait
d'avoir travaillé en France et pas par
le fait d'avoir été français c'est
différent de la logique d'aide sociale
de la SPA
où là c'est un dispositif de solidarité
nationale et pour toucher l'ASPA alors
j'ai plus en tête précisément mais il y
a des conditions de résidence il faut
vivre au moins 6 mois en France et il
faut avoir eu un permis de il faut avoir
une résidence légale de 10 ans en France
avant même de pouvoir toucher le spa
donc voilà sur ce que je peux vous dire
mais la logique des retraites ce n'est
pas de considérer différemment et c'est
la logique contributive du système de
retraite j'ajoute que c'est aussi ce que
nous attendons à réticrocité pour les
Français qui travaillent en Allemagne en
Suisse au Luxembourg heureusement qu'il
y a une reconnaissance internationale
des droits à la retraite pour pour nous
ressortissants frontaliers ou espatrié
aux États-Unis au Japon voilà donc il y
a aussi des Français qui travaillent à
l'étranger et qui bénéficient de
retraite étrangère lorsqu'il rentre en
France
sur la capitalisation
nous ne cartons aucun paradigme vous le
verrez dans les réunions du corps il y a
eu des réunions consacrées à l'épargne
retraite sachant que il y a des
dispositifs de capitalisation en France
c'est pas interdit donc il y a des
produits d'épargne retraite
pour le moment ils sont facultatifs et
donc ou alors il peut être ils peuvent
être rendus obligatoires par un accord
collectif dans une entreprise mais pour
l'essentiel ils sont facultatif
nous n'avons pas étudié l'hypothèse de
rendre une capitalisation obligatoire
étant donné le niveau de
notre système de retraite par
répartition est quand même en
comparaison internationale relativement
généreux et donc je vois mal imposer aux
actifs aujourd'hui de cotiser un
répartition pour la retraite de leurs
anciens et en plus de cotiser pour
eux-mêmes de manière obligatoire dans la
capitalisation mais ceux qui veulent
investir et épargner un capitalisation
bien évidemment c'est c'est possible
voilà
durée de vie
je crois que j'ai répondu
je ne sais plus ce que je lui ai répondu
à tout je ne suis pas sûr mais
voilà vous avez donc ça c'est
une production de l'Insee de Nathalie
Blanpain elle a calculé l'espérance de
vie à 65 ans donc c'est pas à la
retraite strictement mais autour des
âges qu'on prend la retraite par sexe et
par niveau de vie éventuel donc chacun
des points c'est un groupe de 5% de
niveau de vie donc vous avez 20 points
et donc ça se lit de cette manière pour
les hommes quelqu'un qui est dans les 5%
les moins aisés en termes du niveau de
vie à une espérance de vie en 65 ans de
15,8 et quelqu'un qui est parmi les plus
élevé c'est à dire plus de
5500 euros par mois de niveau de vie il
a une espérance de
21,8 donc en gros vous avez un écart de
6 et vous avez cet écart également
sur le sur les femmes vous voyez que
c'est
c'est un gradient tout au long de tout
au long de la croissance du niveau de
vie on pourrait on pouvait on pourrait
penser que quand on est très pauvre et
en difficulté on a moins d'espérance de
vie là il semble que chaque fois qu'on a
un peu plus de niveau de vie et bien on
a un peu plus d'espérance de vie donc
effectivement
et bien
qui ont la moindre le moins d'espérance
de vie à la retraite c'est souvent les
invalides et les inaptes donc là j'ai
pas les chiffres là mais il y a des
travaux et ces personnes là
ne sont pas concernés par la réforme en
termes de recul de l'âge de la retraite
d'accord mais c'est bien évidemment ces
gens là qui font déjà affectés dans leur
corps avant l'âge de la retraite
puisqu'ils sont validé une apte qui est
ensuite ont
les durées de vie les plus courtes à la
retraite mais je le répète ils ne sont
pas concernés par la réforme
je vous avais demandé
pas trop longtemps si
j'en crois que production automnale
alors
donc nous n'avons pas fait de projection
avec
un intégrant la réforme du gouvernement
par construction
le gouvernement nous dit on sera à
l'équilibre en 2030 alors je sais pas si
on peut revenir sur la courbe des
déficits
donc vous voyez
si on est à l'équilibre en 2030 dans la
courbe bleue
continuera à être à l'équilibre voilà
dans la courbe Orange il se peut que il
y a encore quelque chose à gratter
au-delà de 2030 voilà je peux pas vous
dire plus précisément mais vous le lisez
sur sur cette courbe quoi parce que ce
qu'il faut voir aussi c'est que en 2030
on fera au maximum des économies
produites par la réforme parce que quand
vous repoussez l'âge vous avez deux
phénomènes vous payez moins de retraite
parce que des gens auxquels vous auriez
payé la retraite ne sont pas en retraite
mais ces gens-là qui sont pour certains
en position d'emplois et qui donc vont
continuer à travailler auront des
retraites plus élevées d'ailleurs le
d'ailleurs le l'étude d'impact le montre
et progressivement ces gens-là avec des
retraites plus élevées ils vont venir
peupler
excusez-moi du terme le stock des
retraités d'accord et donc
l'économie initiale liée à un report de
l'âge de la retraite
se réduit progressivement sans siroder
tout à fait elle a fait il arrête
sachant que à ce niveau-là j'insiste sur
la différence si vous continuez à
travailler à Harco agir
o agir toute rose cotisé vous donne des
droits
au régime général et dans les régimes
fonctionnaires et spéciaux c'est un peu
différent parce qu'on a ce qu'on appelle
dans notre jargon à nous des retraites
le bornage à eux du coefficient de
progratisation je vais vous dire ce qui
est le bornage à un du coefficient de
provatisation c'est que vous savez que
votre retraite elle est calculée en
fonction de votre durée validée par
rapport à votre durée requise si par
exemple vous avez travaillé 40 ans et
que la durée requise ses 43 ans et ben
votre retraite c'est 40 sur 43 ans c'est
40 sur 43 mais si vous travaillez
au-delà des 43 ans on vous fait pas par
exemple 44 on vous fait pas 44 sur 43
ça s'appelle le bornage du coefficient
de proratisation et donc quand on doit
travailler plus
Arco agir qu'on gagne c'est sûr parce
que les cotisations
général c'est pas évident d'accord bien
évidemment si l'année où on travaille
plus on a eu c'est une année extrêmement
fructueuse d'accord ça viendra améliorer
le salaire de référence qui est sur les
25 meilleures années mais si on a
travaillé un an de plus ça sera de toute
façon qu'un 25e donc on gagnera d'autant
plus que la part à coagir est importante
si on est fonctionnaire
et bien il y a pas d'art courir et donc
là le bornage à un du coefficient de
proratisation il joue sur sur tout
d'accord sauf le régime additionnel de
la fonction publique en capitalisation
qui vient compléter la réforme mais qui
est très limité par rapport à ce que
représente Archos mais pour les
fonctionnaires travailler un an de plus
ça peut changer tout parce que si vous
avez une promotion
pendant cette année vous travaillez en
plus si je suis nommé vice-président du
Conseil d'État qui a aucune chance de
l'arrivée pendant l'année où je
travaillerai en plus parce qu'il je dois
continuer ma carrière c'est c'est bonus
parce que la retraite et liquidé sur les
six derniers mois mais si vous n'avez
pas de promotion dans cette dernière
année et si le poêle est gelé et bien
vous allez à la limite perdre dans votre
retraite puisque si le point est gelé si
vous n'avez pas eu d'augmentation enfin
si ça veut dire que vous avez eu une
baisse en valeur réelle de votre salaire
dans l'année d'accord donc vous voyez
combien c'est extrêmement
c'est extrêmement délicat de lire tous
les effets de la tous les effets de la
réforme même pour des gens dont on dit
ils travaillent en an de plus et bien
les gens qui travaillent en Inde de plus
il va y avoir des effets extrêmement
différents
compliqué de lire les effets de les
effets de la réforme même si dans
l'étude d'impact que vous avez des
données des données synthétiques
très bien merci monsieur le Président
pour l'ensemble des informations qui au
moins amène à tous des informations sur
la complexité on en doutait pas